welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is a bit of a different styled
episode about a month ago
there was big news about pornhub visa
and mastercard dropped them for
apparently hosting child pornography
and it looked like a lot of it they
removed 10 million videos
i decided to have a few people on to
discuss pornhub sex work
and whether or not porn and sex work is
dangerous harmful and addictive
or whether it's a natural thing that
should be decriminalized and even
possibly encouraged
i had no idea there was this war going
on between pro and anti-porn people
but the war against pornhub has
certainly shot a bit of a light on it
and i thought it'd be interesting to see
opposing views on a controversial topic
given the fact we're usually completely
isolated from opposing views
and that's causing serious problems at
the moment
i spoke first with haley mcnamara vp
at the international center on sexual
exploitation
haley's non-profit is largely
responsible for bringing the issue of
child exploitation on pornhub into the
public eye
and getting over 10 million videos from
unverified uploaders removed from
pornhub december 2020
she's in the first half of the episode
the second half of the episode is with
nicole prousey
a neuroscientist that researches human
sexual behavior addiction
and the physiology of sexual response
she's also the founder of liberos llc
an independent research institute these
people have
pretty much completely opposing views so
it was an interesting couple of
conversations
this was the first episode like this let
me know if you find the format
or the idea of opposing views podcasts
interesting regardless of the topic i
may do more of these episodes
speaking of opposing views and not
seeing them this episode is brought to
you by ground news
a sponsor of the show and a canadian
company i support
they're a comparison platform for news
so rather than trying to find an
unbiased news platform which is
virtually impossible
ground news will compare how sources
from across the political spectrum are
covering a story
so you can easily see whether or how
outlets are manipulating a story to fit
an
underlying narrative very necessary this
year
they have an app called ground news for
your phone so obviously you can check
that out
ground news is an apolitical news app
only interested in giving you the full
story regardless of your political
ideology i recommend downloading the
free ground news app
and browser extension you can click on
the link in the description below or
show notes or go to ground.news
thanks for sponsoring the show enjoy the
[Music]
episode
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's been big news about pornhub so i'm
going to read a brief intro from
the verge pornhub is removing all videos
uploaded to its site by
unverified users millions of videos in
total
as a part of a crackdown on user
uploaded content after two major
payment processors that be visa and
mastercard's suspended service
the decision stems from a new york times
report that found the site was hosting
videos of people who are underage
and videos showing children being
assaulted i would assume
videos of people who are underage also
refer to children
the site announced that it would begin
limiting uploads to verified users only
uploads now have to come from official
content partners or members of pornhab's
model program which requires age
verification to sign up
motherboard reports that all previously
uploaded videos are now being
pulled pending verification in review
beginning in 2021.
so that's more than 10 million videos
have been wiped out
uh and then pornhub released this from a
blog post which i think is kind of funny
quote this means every piece of pornhub
content is from verified uploaders
a requirement that platforms like
facebook instagram ticktalk youtube
snapchat and twitter
have yet to institute as if those are
equivalent platforms and they're also
hosting children
children's porn child porn pornhub
appears to have wiped out more than 10
million videos and had boasted 13.5
million videos
sunday night and it currently has 2.9
million
as of monday morning anyway uh so
that's kind of huge news i've i've heard
that they're now operating mainly with
bitcoin and pornhub is a huge website
so i am now pleased very pleased to have
a conversation
with haley mcnamara and i'm going to
introduce you right now
haley welcome to my podcast hi
nice to be here thank you thank you for
coming on at such short notice
uh can you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is that you do
yes so
i am vice president at the national
center on
sexual exploitation and i direct our new
international division which just
launched this year
our organization is a u.s non-profit
nonpartisan we work on
all issues of sexual exploitation and
abuse recognizing that we can't solve
sex trafficking in a vacuum
it's actually deeply related to issues
like pornography prostitution
child abuse and much more so we do work
on policy on corporate responsibility
and we lead a international coalition of
a lot of ngos and advocates so
you guys were the organization or at
least one of the organizations that went
to mastercard and visa and urged them to
look into what was going on at pornhub
yes so we first reached out to them uh
in january february of this year
in february at least one i think both in
february told us that they were starting
investigations into the content on
pornhub
i personally had meetings um with some
pretty high up people over there a
couple of times
explaining to them the issues that are
going on on pornhub
they were shocked and concerned
said that they would start looking into
it uh which obviously they did but it
really took the new york times
article to push them into that action
stage
yeah okay so the news
vaguely it didn't surprise me but it
kind of surprised
me uh what exactly
from your point of view what was going
on at pornhub
so i would say pornhub is a bad actor
there's a number of issues with their
site
one they allow unverified videos to
upload
no age or consent verification not even
like you take a box to say that i'm over
18
which wouldn't be enough um just to be
on the record also you can download
the videos off of pornhub so um we
started a couple years ago hearing from
survivors
that their child sexual abuse materials
or child pornography
or videos of when they were being sex
trafficked videos of
their sexual assaults were continually
being uploaded
to pornhub and then it can be shared and
downloaded etc
uh we i mean we also know the issue goes
even further i mean pornhub has a mirror
site on the dark web which most people
don't know about
why would they need that other than we
know what the dark web is for it's for
illegal content so
that's a thing of a matter of concern um
and we also know that there really is no
metric
to measure consent that pornhub could
could even verify for the videos being
uploaded
to their site if someone is being sex
trafficked
they can also be coerced into smiling
for the camera or even into
signing a contract and that's happened
before um in the girls do porn
lawsuit there were over 20 women who
were sex trafficked
um into the legal porn industry and
pornhub knew that there were lawsuits
going on
about this case uh and pornhub knew and
left
the channel up even just a couple of
months ago that we know that there are
still
videos of those sex trafficked girls
were on pornhub
so just they are absolutely a bad actor
here
from another angle and this is obviously
coming from pornhub this is written in
the star
which is canadian press the company also
claims it is being unfairly targeted by
groups wanting to end pornography
and commercial sex work and not being
treated based on its policies or how it
compares to its peers
um so what percentage say of the videos
removed and
i mean the articles came out and it was
like mastercard is currently
looking into pornhub mastercard has
dropped pornhub
right which doesn't look great and then
the same thing happened with visa i
think paypal dropped it a while ago is
that true
it did last year and discover is a
credit card that has also dropped
pornhub
yeah so that doesn't look good but then
you could say well they're just being
careful
um so what percentage of and that's 10
million out of like 13 million videos
are gone
so most of the website i didn't realize
i had that many videos that's an insane
number
but what percentage of those
do you think actually harbored some sort
of illegal content
it's tough to say i wouldn't have a
really
verified way of saying the percentage
but
i'm pretty confident to say a
significant percentage of them
you know if if you went on pornhub you
could find
compilations of stolen snapchat videos
you could search for
revenge pornography or non-consensually
shared pornography
um so it's it was it was a lot it was a
lot not a lot of people are just
uploading themselves it's a lot of
non-consensually shared content
yeah i was all i was always under the
assumption that those were just
click-baity titles
and that the actual video was not what
the title
explained it as it's much more
concerning if you assume that the title
is accurate
yeah sometimes the title is accurate
sometimes it's not
but that's that's the problem right like
pornhub isn't walmart it doesn't
like selling a product is different than
selling sex like the level with what
consent
means when it comes to sexual activity
versus like a
contract is is very different sexual
consent is far more nuanced and it's
more
important in a lot of ways so yeah
yeah it's tough for anyone to know
what's consensual or not on their
website
can you describe exactly what sex
trafficking is
versus something that's more consensual
because i always had the idea
and perhaps this is a naive idea it
probably is that
you have you know in the good setup you
have a porn studio you have people doing
porn
they're paid everyone's aware of what
they're doing no one's
traumatized from the experience i don't
even know if that's possible
but you know everyone's paid it's fairly
safe
maybe they're acting and then everyone
goes home so what's the difference
between that kind of situation and then
sex trafficking
so sex trafficking is basically an
exchange of something for value of value
for sex uh in when there is force
fraud or coercion and coercion is
a really big yeah like i said
we need to think about well what's
actually a coercive factor in that
person's life
all the articles that are on buzzfeed or
whatever um that say some celebrities
gone on only fans and made millions of
dollars like
those people don't care they're just
honored because they think it's funny
right
not because they're being forced or
coerced into it
okay so what are so what's the
overarching goal of what you do
i want the world to recognize
these connections between different
forms of sexual exploitation
if you talk to anyone they will say sex
trafficking is terrible
and i want to end it but then they'll go
and they'll watch pornography
and have no question in their mind about
well maybe they're contributing to the
problem in some way
um so i want that lens to be reflected
in our policies
at the government level and also
corporations one of the reasons why we
went and met with visa and mastercard
is because it we can see it makes a big
difference when a corporation
legitimizes something by by enacting
with it and
i'm i'm not a canceled culture person
that's that's not what i'm talking about
um but i think we can all decide we want
to cancel child
sexual abuse like i think that's
something that we should all be able to
rally around
so uh so i think it's important when a
corporation
does that and i also think you know it's
fascinating to see corporations that are
really quick
um to respond to political issues but
there's yeah yes like happening on their
platform and
it's it's inconsistent how they what
they prioritize
well i think they just reflect what
crowds are prioritizing
mm-hmm that is concerning that they yeah
that that is concerning
okay so apparently apparently
now pornhub has only verified content on
there
and they're only going to be allowing
content from verified users
do you know what that means what is a
verified user on pornhub
so right now what their system has been
is you take a picture of yourself
and your uh government id
uh and you like write what your username
is like on your hand or something
and you send that photo in
not very verified like
again like someone could absolutely be
trafficked and
so pornhub is trying to say that you
know we should all
look away look away from them because
they're doing this now so they're fine
now
now they're on equal level with twitter
and facebook right
but no but i mean they have they have
had sex trafficked videos
verified on their website they've had
miners
videos verified on their website so that
means
no i mean like good like i mean i'm glad
that
you know they removed all this
unverified content i personally know
survivors who are finally
breathing a sigh of relief because of
the trauma that they
experience the fact that people are
continuing to watch their abuse
that's horrific i'm glad those videos
are down
but this new verification system i mean
we're going to have the same
problem continue to pop up
yeah that is concerning and i guess
people weren't well people are certainly
thinking about it now but there was
always the concern that
i always had a concern not that i should
share that necessarily but i always had
a concern something would end up on
pornhub
and i knew that there was no way to like
who do you contact
you email hey that's me and i'm not okay
with that being up there
yeah it's and we've had you know
survivors have
contacted pornhub and said hey i was a
minor and i was
a this was an assault will you take the
video down
and pornhub left it up multiple times
people who've tried to contact them for
years
they typically would only reply after
lawyers got involved
um and then still users could re-upload
that content
later on and they would do that and so
this is one reason why
you know survivors have a really hard
time speaking out
who have experienced harmful things in
the pornography industry
or we've had you know pornographic
images made of them while they were
trafficked or abused
because what happens it can
it lives on and people continue to
re-upload it
to the internet even after it's been
taken down and that kind of takes a
long-term trauma you know we've had
survivors have said how
they were trafficked once for a period
of time that is now over
but their abuse feels constant because
they know people are still engaging with
like they're they're still engaging with
that material
yeah well hearing that they host child
pornography probably means they should
not be around
right right i mean i guess
yeah it's scary what do you think's
gonna happen
you think they've bit the dust it's not
looking great right now
it's not looking great i think i think
that they're gonna go
down there have been a number of
survivors who've already started
suing them and i think we're gonna see
more and more of that
very quickly and i think within the next
couple of months we're gonna see another
round of lawsuits
and honestly i i that i'm
fighting for them to go down i i don't
think that they're
um a company that operates in good faith
in any
way you've definitely made progress with
pornhub that's pretty big it's been
pretty big news trending on twitter
it's a it's a pretty seismic culture
moment that we're in the middle of right
now
and and there's it's not over yet the
canadian federal
parliament committee is going to be
calling mind geek which is the owner of
pornhub
i'm in to testify about these issues um
i
i hope that there's going to be some
some government uh investigation
of the website i bet that there will be
uh that's we're certainly calling for
that
um so i i think that people are starting
to
wake up to the recognition and you know
not everyone's mind is going to be
changed about it but i think enough
people's minds can be changed
that our society addresses pornography
in a different way that we say this does
cause harmful impact um to users
it's science it's been proven uh your
life is gonna be better without it
and also a significant number of
performers are harmed in
in the production so i think that
in a couple of years everyone will be
pretending that they knew pornhub was
bad
all along yeah i wouldn't be surprised
i wouldn't be surprised i wouldn't be
surprised if this also means that sites
like only fans are going to be
super careful going forward
which is a step in the right direction
at least um for child pornography it's
like oh
now that pornhub is under scrutiny we
all whoever else is harboring stuff like
that we better be super careful because
with pornhub
my assumption would have been it got so
big
that it wasn't controlled so initially
they started like yeah make it like
youtube but for porn right and then it
was like oh we've got 13 million videos
and no wonder we haven't sorted through
them all
um and then they just hadn't put in
any verification which shocks me i mean
there must have been a little button you
could press that said
i am not exploiting anybody not that i
know
i mean it was they weren't they didn't
even have a button for are you over 18
i mean and as you know this this isn't
current we'll know more after the
canadian like committee
grills mind geek but um a couple of
years ago they only had
six moderators to review content wow
that is crazy they must have been making
hoards of money
they don't have any employees yeah
they're
they're a huge company so pornhub is
like one sub company
it's it's owned by mind geek they're
based in canada they've got headquarters
all over the world
though they're probably in montreal yeah
i'm from like i'm not just throwing in a
quebec insult there i'm from montreal
but they probably
are they are they are there you go
they own more websites than just pornhub
um
they also own like they've created their
own
advertising company called traffic
junkie their own payment processing
company that you would like to
credit card into called pro biller they
have built up
like an entire ecosystem around
pornography
they rake in hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars
every year uh and they're not concerned
about the individuals who are in those
videos they are a money making machine
they're not concerned about free they're
not concerned
they are just in it for the money
yeah i remember i was i think it was on
a couple of podcasts earlier this year
and i was like
when when you know twitter is censoring
or facebook censoring a certain content
and i was like oh well
there's always pornhub it doesn't censor
anything which apparently is true
yeah it's true wow
okay well where can people find you
online
so our website oregon uh is
endsexualexploitation.org
uh we're on twitter at newcosync osc
my twitter is haley mcnamara spelled
like it is down here
okay well thank you very much for coming
on that was interesting i wanted to talk
to somebody
in the know about what was going on with
pornhub so
thank you yeah thank you
[Music]
nicole prousey welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me on
so i picked you because i've already
interviewed somebody who had
what i believe is kind of the opposite
stance of what you have in regards to
porn
and there's been a whole bunch of news
about what's gone on at pornhub and them
removing
a ton of videos visa and mastercard
dropping them
so i wanted to get kind of the opposite
opinion and just
put both of your guys's opinions out
there and just to
kind of inform people about what's going
on because i had no idea that there was
i read an article called porn wars i
didn't know that there
was anything going on with people who
are like
shut it down completely it's poisonous
to the mind get rid of it entirely
and then there are people who are on the
opposite side of that so
could you start off by just giving
people listening a
bit of a brief background about who you
are and what it is that you do
i'm a neuroscientist so i mainly study
the effects of pornography
on humans and relationships from the
perspective of like mechanism so
if someone says porn is affecting me
negatively i say well how
you know what is the nature of that
problem but then i'm also a licensed
psychologist in california
so i also see and treat patients some of
whom have these types of issues
so a lot of the questions i'm interested
in are when people walk in my door and
say
you know i'm having trouble with
pornography understanding what the
nature of that
really is so i can help them in the best
way
okay so from from your point of view
what i've heard happened at pornhub is
they got pursued by
companies um and the claim was they're
hosting child pornography or
unconsensual
pornography and that all got removed
from
so from from here you know theoretically
so from your point of view
what happened at pornhub my
senses you know i don't work with any
pornography companies so i don't have
insight into their
processes and vetting films or how they
deal with those kinds of issues
but within the scientific community we
have the association for the treatment
of
sex offenders where we really work on
prevention
of those types of concerns so people who
may be coerced into providing a film or
maybe they were consenting at the time
but not to its distribution
those things are absolutely happening
and scientists are very concerned about
them and we would love to be able to
prevent that
so my sense was you know the selection
of a porn company
that doesn't seem to be generating the
content
is effort completely misplaced i don't
think the scientific community thinks
that's a
useful way of approaching sexual abuse i
don't think it's a useful way of
approaching sexual abuse it's unlikely
to have
the impact uh or help for those folks
who i think
they believe it well so what would what
would your uh advice be
for how to i guess combat the
unconsensual stuff that's put out
yeah i think there are a number of
different levels and some of it is
uh reaching out to kids they're a number
now of
research supported porn intervention
programs that kind of
teach kiddos as they're learning about
their sexuality
you know what to think about when you
agree to let someone take an
image of you or you transmit your own
sexual image and to be very clear that's
not to blame
them for creating those you know it's a
recognition that
kids explore sexually and it's going to
happen and so how do we make sure that
they
are also helping protect themselves you
know not
responding to people making inquiries on
the internet
um and i know there are also some
colleagues who are working more on the
technological end
i know less about that but i'm really
interested in seeing what we might do
for example to create chat monitors to
see when there are patterns that look
like
someone's trying to solicit a child so
that they might again we want to prevent
these
if we can stop them from being made
initially um
then we're not worried about you know
people trying to attack a platform
you know we really want it to be cut off
before it occurs if we can
yeah so education education for for
kids largely education especially with
the child material is i think a lot of
kids
kind of don't realize um if they
initially consent to some of those
images
being created or shared that it's
probably not
going to re you know remain within the
bounds of their sexual exploration as
they might have intended
okay okay um and then what's your so
some of the arguments put forth by these
uh more anti-porn
groups there's there's a couple of them
and one is porn
isn't good for you especially when
you're growing up um
it's it's addictive uh and that
it's not good for the people performing
in it
so what are your opinions on those three
topics the three so
in the first case that's uh kids the
problem with children is the only way to
actually know what the impact of
pornography is on children would be to
randomly assign children to view
pornography
that is illegal we do not do that and
so ultimately neither side has a good
argument
in that case you know we don't really
know what the ultimate
impact is on kids um i think that's an
argument though to
you know reduce their interest
in viewing just because we don't know so
there's a risk
potential there um when you get to
adults
and potential negative impacts
there's no doubt that some adults are
clearly coming into our practices and
saying you know i'm having problems
around pornography but the question is
what is the nature of that problem
and the strongest predictor of somebody
identifying themselves as a porn addict
is having a conservative or religious
upbringing
so what that suggests is you know that
doesn't happen with people who have
gambling problems so much
it doesn't happen with um people who are
struggling with heroin use
you know this this is really kind of a
unique issue where the problem seems
strongly driven by
kind of moral imperatives so when you
have groups that are promoting this idea
they're actually causing harm
because they're increasing that false
message that it's inherently harmful for
you
thereby causing people to think you know
just by viewing i've i've hurt my brain
and that's clearly not the case
you know so for example um on average
people report a nationally
representative sample men start viewing
porn
around or first viewed born around age
14 women at 17 and a half
so it's not these incredibly young ages
that you sometimes hear thrown around
but they're still
fairly young and those also tend to be
around the times of sexual debut
so you know i don't know that it's the
porography or really reflecting kind of
a shift in their
sexual activity uh and then in general
you know 94 percent of men around 87
percent of women
say that they have viewed pornography in
their lifetime
yeah so with that many people viewing
obviously they vary and how regular they
view and we have a lot more we could
characterize about that
it's a very tiny percentage that are
saying i struggle
and specifically if you look at again a
nationally representative sample
it's around two percent of men and point
five percent of women who view
who say i've had a negative impact any
negative impact of pornography
so you know that representing um you
know what's the actual impact what's the
level of problem
in the adult population i think seems
relatively small
and those who are identifying seem
largely influenced
by their conservative or religious
upbringing um
and so the last question if you could
help me out was kind of the
dopamine does doesn't it give you like
um i've read a number of studies where
viewing these images theoretically
releases dopamine and that's what makes
it addictive
so the argument would be you know it's
hard for some people to stop
watching or they start watching and they
start with something that's kind of like
soft core porn and they end up in
you know way over on the other side
where it gets pretty rough
and part of that is the addictive
element so
what do you think about that so with the
dopamine plays a number of different
roles uh it does have a role in
rewarding behaviors absolutely it also
plays a large role in movement
as well as other functions of the body
so people often have this idea that if
dopamine is involved it must be
addictive and that is definitely not the
case you know walking is not addictive
and yet dopamine is essential for
walking
but it doesn't like just just to it like
walking doesn't release the same amount
of
dope i mean that something like
ejaculating does right
so actually orgasm does not produce a
spike in dopamine that's been studied in
humans and men and women
uh the dopamine shifts tend to occur
around the sexual arousal period
and actually it's a i'm glad that you
asked that because one of the things
we've been finding
is in studies where you control for a
masturbation
which is primarily what pornography is
used for we find that a lot of these
effects are reversed
that is the supposed negative effects um
so one thing i think is really missing
in this conversation is you know a lot
of the groups that are now opposing
pornhub in the past had uh campaigns
against masturbation
so i'm thinking you know does this
really have anything to do with
concerns about trafficking or is this
your latest manifestation of
anti-sex uh positioning so
you know the a lot of the research
that's being done around pornography
right now we're increasingly pushing
people to say you really have to include
masturbation as a control in your
studies but it's largely not being done
so i always say you know first when i
see those kind of studies like
what if they just looked at the porn do
you really think that would do anything
you know is it really oh that's kind of
interesting well yeah
i was going i was going to say there's
got to be um an addictive element to it
one because when you watch it it's like
it's a little it's shocking right
unless you i guess you desensitize
yourself but initially it's surprising
so you get kind of an adrenaline rush
when
you watch it but you can become addicted
to
like people get addicted to their cars
right there's that slippery slope of you
know if we call everything addictive
then nothing's addictive so we want to
be
i tend to be a bit more conservative
kind of in what i include and
you know we have some pretty strong
rules around what
kinds of things seems to constitute an
addiction it's just
addiction has a very specific meaning in
science that i think the public
uses a little more loosely so yeah do
people like do
people go into any type of if they're
used to
say that they get some sort of pleasure
hormone and that that is
some sort of addiction do they go into
an actual withdrawal when they stop
it's interesting if you ask people
directly like do you have withdrawal
from pornography they'll report
that they do but then we can't find any
evidence for it when we actually look
like in longitudinal studies and
physiology
we don't see evidence for that and
similarly like you report about the
escalation
studies have looked at that
longitudinally and absolutely if you ask
people directly
like do you think that you were
desensitized you think that you
escalated they say yes i believe that i
do
but if you actually follow them over
time there's not evidence for that
and we see that in laboratory studies as
well that is
even someone who i've shown a fair
amount of pornography to um they're very
responsive again very quickly
um so for example someone who has an
extensive porn viewing history so they
come and they tell us we've seen it all
you know when i look at it every day and
i look at their brain's response to some
really vanilla pornography we use pretty
boring stuff in my lab because it's
tightly regulated
yeah and their brain is just as
responsive as anyone else's
so they're not desensitized um and i
think that's largely because people who
view a lot of pornography
have a higher sex drive so they're more
responsive to sexual stimuli in general
um and so that but that idea kind of
that you're
mentioning that people escalate over
time is uh has been widely circulated
and just scientists don't have pr
agencies you know we don't go and um try
and
uh tout our findings in that way and so
i think part of what's happened is the
science has been perverted by these
groups who want to use it
you know to fulfill an agenda like
they're trying to make legislative
change
and we're just trying to do science and
i don't think the science supports
that okay switching topics slightly
um my concern i guess about
well i didn't i didn't really have much
of a concern about porn because
for whatever reason i have concerns
about other things but things like um
say only fans there's the positive
aspect
uh where it gives people who
are either already doing kind sex work
it gives them
what appears on the outside a safer kind
of environment where
pay is regulated and there's you know
worse everyone's socially distancing now
so you can do it
via socially distancing so there's that
side and then when you talk to people
who are kind of anti-that and i'm not
necessarily pro or auntie any of this
but
you talk to people who are anti-that and
they're saying well you know for
a very very tiny percentage of people on
a site like only fans
they're making a ton of money they're
having a like a great time
but for the majority of people on there
it's still
sex work it's hard on their brain
it's not good for them and they're not
making any money so part of my concern i
guess would
about normalizing that kind of behavior
is
for the majority of people it's probably
not
a positive experience so what have you
like as a psychologist what have you
seen
in regards to something like only fans
yeah so i think you're
hitting on something that a lot of
people do believe so when college
students were asked you know how much
money do you think the webcam models
make they
grossly overestimated what they uh made
and so i think that's
a common problem is if someone goes into
it not understanding what the financial
structure is actually like
that's a problem you know they should
have good information so they can make a
decision
about whether or not that's something
they want to do but when you ask webcam
performers directly
what are the benefits of the jobs uh
they cite three generally as their top
um benefits so one is the flexibility of
hours which is just a basic work benefit
you know that is i can turn it on
whenever i
uh i'm ready to work the finances so
presumably there's some
you know financial gain that they feel
is worth uh doing that kind of work
and then the last one is sexual arousal
so that they actually
themselves believe that it's pleasurable
which is something they often claim
doesn't occur in sex workers and of
course it occurs in a lot of sex workers
not
for everyone obviously but in that case
i think a lot of them do experience that
and to
pretend like that's not happening and
they're all you know enslaved is a
perspective that discounts their
experience entirely it's not consistent
with the data at all
now that said uh some absolutely are
having bad experiences
and what i would love to see is
something that's
more up front for um those who are
trying to enter the industry that don't
have sufficient information
so for example you know what is
reasonable you know what are the consent
laws in pornography like how
does the consent that i may have learned
about my college course or my high
school
about sex ed how does that come into
play when i'm doing this on film or i'm
doing this in a
webcam setting you know how do i protect
myself for example so that people don't
stalk and harass me
if they feel they can use the stigma of
my work to try and come after me
and that i would really love to see more
work around like how can
we ensure that people who are entering
the industry have good information going
in so that they're able to make an
informed judgment
and protect themselves yeah that's that
all seems reasonable
um have you seen i guess like
personally i would assume that
a lot of women who end up doing some
sort of
even something like only fans when
they're young say maybe under 23
and this is just my opinion but i would
assume once you get older that
can be tough for people to look back on
and that your opinion not everyone's
going to have that obviously but your
experience and your opinion especially
if society is saying
this is totally fine like uh this should
be
completely normalized and then you end
up doing something like that and then
you get married you have kids or
something and you're like you know what
i was actually kind of uncomfortable
there but i thought it was okay at the
time
and so my main concern would be as a
society because we're going
we're not really going in the anti-porn
direction realistically
um we're more going in the pro porn
direction i would say we're
like society's getting pretty liberal so
my concern would be
if we say that this is totally normal
and completely normalize it isn't going
aren't we going to end up with a bunch
of people who
are saying like who end up kind of hurt
by the fact they did that kind of thing
later in life
what have you seen i think you're right
with that trend so
a large survey of uk students found one
and five of them had considered doing
sex work
either yeah or one of those sugar daddy
things or something like that
it's incredibly common i think and five
percent said they've actually engaged in
some form of sex work
and so when you go into it they say the
most negative
uh effect that they experience from it
is the social stigma
so that is exactly kind of i think what
you're describing that is
you know are they going to have some
life development down the line where
they say
you know this is now a problem and the
type of work i want to do or
you know i really want to be with this
partner and this partner doesn't approve
of you know my past uh experience in
this area
yeah well that or or maybe they actually
just don't feel good about it
like not just socially but i mean for
themselves
the social stigma is the one that's uh
that they cite by far as the most common
negative but absolutely so that's what i
mean with the education kind of going in
is i do think there are some women who
enter and don't kind of have a good
um broad perspective of you know when
they're signing their rights to these
films what exactly are they signing you
know they
may not have attorneys available to them
they may not know what those contracts
mean or what a good or a bad contract
looks like
and i'd love for women to have that
information i say women but actually
more men are involved in cambric and uh
sex work than women
so um yeah that's a bit of a
misstatement but
uh people in general you know i'd love
for them to have kind of good
information going in
so that they can hopefully reduce that
later regret
yeah that sounds tricky i mean people
get screwed over at work all the time
that has nothing to do with sex work
especially by companies that are like
stick this into a contract
that seems that seems tricky to navigate
you want this job
a job or not you know you got it yeah in
terms totally and so i think you're
hitting on a good
point there that is you know some of the
things that people say oh you know this
is terrible about sex work we think
kind of sounds like job satisfaction in
general you know so
like when i mentioned one of the main um
things that
sex workers cite as a benefit of doing
uh indirect sex work like
cam work is uh they say it's hours
flexibility you know like that's
yeah flexible hours is a really common
thing you want in a job in general even
if you're not doing sex work so
um you know i i really love that kind of
pointing out that you know this is
another form of work or labor and they
have similar kinds of concerns
for being satisfied in their job
yeah some similar the the regretting it
later i mean it depends on the job
regretting it later might be a little
bit higher in the
in the sex work category from i mean
i've talked to you like i
i have friends that are i have friends
that are uh doing only fans or
or um who've stripped or something and
i would say generally speaking
they don't feel that good about it later
but not everybody
some people are some people are totally
cool with that and and i guess my view
would be i'd like i don't like putting
restrictions on anybody
so i wouldn't want to i i don't think
actively encouraging it and completely
normalizing it is good
because i'm concerned about the people
who don't really know what they're
getting into and the effects that might
have later
but then you don't want to ban people or
harass people for doing like just leave
everybody alone
that's that could be my monitor just
like leave everyone alone
that's absolutely one of the things
that's increased in the pandemic is
more people are starting to do online
sex work and yeah
yeah you see it too i i see it for sure
on instagram like
a bunch of people who well they have an
only fans thing in their title
yeah and but we're in a weird time i
mean people are
strapped for cash like people are not in
this is a weird year yeah well i think
you're hitting on again one of those
kind of reasons some people enter is you
know they
it is a way to make money that they can
potentially do from home they can set
their own hours they can set their rates
um and you know i've seen that in some
of my clients that i see clinically i
see adults
um in my practice and those that are
involved in that
type of sex work you know it's been
really important for them
uh some of them and the pandemic they
say like i wouldn't make my bills
otherwise
you know there's no way um and so
so far you know they're having positive
experiences and i hope that you know we
can set them up to
continue to experience that in a
positive way and have it be good
employment for as long as they want it
okay thank you thank you very much for
coming on absolutely thanks for talking
about the topic appreciate it
[Music]
you